Okay, so here we are again our holistic health, our number three, so we just have started these. I've been doing Zoom calls with our cancer members for
like seven years now, weekly Zoom calls. We actually do two week now with our full membership and these courses are due, so
just started these.
So all right, so we have several submitted questions, so I'll get to those in a reminder, just submit your questions on the site where it says submit your question here and we will try to get to it.
So first question, how is Lyme disease diagnosed if you are exactly sure, I think they're asking if you don't know if you've never been diagnosed, you think you have the symptoms of Lyme disease and
but you don't know if you haven't or not. So if you're on the Lyme course, I go into detail with the different tests that you can do.
But if you're not on the Lyme course, you don't have that access. I would just point you to my favorite test, which is the DNA connections test that's on our store, so you can go to our store and search DNA connections, but it's spelled where it is.
DNA, CO, and EXI, I think something like that. So if you start typing it, you'll probably see that or just type, Lyme test, the nice thing about it, it is a urine test.
So it's easy to do at home, we ship you the kit, you just follow the instructions and come with the kit, and you send it back in and they test for not just the Burellia so Lyme disease is Burellia burgodorphy and then there's, I think it tests for 13 different co infections as well, which is really nice.
In a test, if you were ever exposed to it, if you ever had it, it doesn't tell you the severity of your Lyme disease, it doesn't tell you what stage of Lyme you may be in, it doesn't tell you
quantifiable details like that, but it will tell you if you have had Lyme disease in the past, it doesn't, still doesn't tell you whether your symptoms, your current set of symptoms are caused by Lyme disease, there's no way to tell those things.
So that has just clinical data that you have to kind of ascertain with the history and you're still basically just making clinical assumptions and guesses on that.
But it's very beneficial if you have like severe symptoms that could tie back to Lyme disease to do test for that because that can change your treatment parameters and what you would want to do.
So DNA connections is my favorite one, though there's lots of Lyme labs popping up down, there's a lot of different labs that are out there.
The isogenics is much more complicated, it and it's much more expensive, so I like the DNA connections the best.
How do you know if it's a good idea to do a Syrex test, so if you haven't dug into any of the sites that talk about Syrex testing any of the, I don't know what course, I talk about it a lot on the Lyme course, I talk about it in the detox course that I'm going to go into it in big detail on the autoimmune course that's coming out in January or February, because Syrex testing is very specific antibody testing.
So it's Syrex is the name of the lab and they currently have about 15 different arrays as you can test for their most common one is the antibody testing for food antibodies, so for food sensitivities, it is the most specific comprehensive test available.
I would even trust any of the other lab tests that are out there for food sensitivities, I would only do the Syrex.
It's also really good for if you think that you have an autoimmune disease.
If you have a lot of people that are suspected they have Lyme disease again, and that they have a lot of neuronal issues like brain function issues and such to do what's called the Syrex 7x array 7x is very valuable because
it tests for neuronal antibodies, do you have antibodies to any brain tissue, that could be really helpful and in your treatment parameters is super helpful because if you have antibodies to neuronal tissue, there's very specific things that you have to really be careful with.
So I actually in the autoimmune course are going to have videos on all of these arrays, so it's it's going to be extensive, so what is it a good idea to do a Syrex test if you suspect the autoimmune disease if you suspect food sensitivities of any kind that's where you do a Syrex test.
I think I might have thyroid problems, what's the best test for that? Well, for thyroid issues you, that's a standard lab test and you want to test for do a thyroid panel, like to scroll off the top of my head I'm going to type some of those things in that you would test for.
So typically if you go into your doctor, you say I want to have my thyroid tested, they'll test for TSH which is thyroid stimulating hormone.
Well, thyroid stimulating hormone is actually produced by the pituitary gland and it's basically telling the thyroid to release more formal, so if the thyroid stimulating hormone is elevated, that's a hint that you might have low thyroid.
But that is so inconclusive, you don't just test TSH and then say you have a thyroid type of thyroid issue, you have to test for the thyroid hormone, so what are the thyroid hormones, so you got T3, T3 is the active thyroid hormone, but it's really only about 6% of what the thyroid gland produces.
The thyroid gland really produces 94% T4, so T4 is not in an active hormone state, it doesn't have any physical activity to any of the cells, T4 then converts to T3 in the liver and in the gut at a timely fashion.
So when your body needs it, over the course of the day, T4 will convert to T3.
Well, problem is, then you want to know how much free T3 and free T4 is, so you would also test for free T3 and you would also test for free T4.
And then you'd also test for a thing that's called reverse T3, because if you have a sick gut, then your T4, instead of converting to T3, it converts to this other compound that is inactive and can never become active, and that's called reverse T3.
So you want to test for the percentage of reverse T3 you have, because you might have adequate T4, adequate T3, but you have very elevated T, reverse T3, and that's the side of that thyroid issues, but gut issues and possibly liver issues.
And then you also want to test for TPO antibodies, because that will tell you if you possibly have Hashimoto's.
So that is a more complete thyroid panel. You really want to get, you know, when we order thyroid panels for people, we order them to lab core, and then we also get, you know, a CBC and complete metabolic panel with that too.
Because we want to look at how the liver is doing, how the rest of the body is doing, how your blood is doing, that's your complete blood count, and your complete metabolic panel.
That's a more appropriate thyroid function test.
By recent blood test shows a serum ferritin of seven. So serum ferritin of seven is low.
I would like to know if you have ever heard of the research by Morley Robbins at his new book, copper cure for fatigue, but I don't have the T. He has been researching this for 10 years and discusses the critical role of copper and regulated iron.
Prior to this, I had high iron. My doctor has ordered a copper test and a seroplasm test and magnesium red blood cell test, any comment on all of this?
Well, serum ferritin of seven is low, and usually that has to do with some sort of anemia.
It doesn't always have to do with an iron anemia, meaning that your iron levels can be normal to this person. They said their iron levels are actually elevated.
It can be a B12 anemia as well. That can cause a ferritin level of low. Now B12 anemia or a codicious anemia can be caused from a genetic factor.
The genes that help you bring iron across the gut wall. More commonly, it's caused from an issues with your gut, you know, needing some gut healing because you have some gut damage.
Now, commenting on the copper, the cure for fatigue, I would be very careful about that because there is a whole another phenomenon with copper.
People can get way too much copper and end up with copper toxicity and copper and zinc have a very definitive relationship within your body.
If you have excess copper stored in your tissues, that can lead, that can be a major thing that leads to cancer.
So, one of the things you test for in cancer patients quite often is your copper zinc ratio because it's usually off you have excess copper and low zinc.
People commonly have a zinc deficiency, especially with excess copper, that if you start taking zinc, you can get sick because you will dump, you will push copper out of the cells and you can become, you can, you can feel, will flourish even.
It's really like a Berksheimer reaction because you're dumping excess copper that could be so harmful to your cells.
So, I'm not a big fan of taking excess copper. All of our cancer members, we don't let them take supplements with copper.
So, copper can drive cancer. Copper is a, what is copper, you need copper, understand, but you should get that in your vegetables. I don't think you should be taking copper in your supplements.
A lot of multiple vitamins will have a milligram of copper in there which is ideally, you know, recommended allowance of copper, which I guess that's fine.
But even with our cancer patients, I don't want them to get anything more than that with copper because copper is a growth factor. Copper increases growth.
Certainly don't want their cancer, but you certainly don't want that with anything else either.
So, I'm not a big fan of taking copper at all. So, you know, I just, not a big fan of that work.
Just with what I've seen. A lot of people can have issues, more issues with excess copper than issues with too low of copper.
Remember, with any of the minerals, you really need to be careful.
Even if you're taking minerals, you want to make sure the way that the supplement is that you are, that it's keylated correctly. So, let me explain.
There was a big bad going on a couple of years ago that, you know, you need to be cooking with cast-iron pans because it's so good for you because cast-iron pans are iron, and that's a good way to get your iron.
That effect, they came out with these little eye cast-iron little, like a little duck or a cast-iron little chicken.
And you should put it in when you're boiling water for potatoes, throw that right in your pot because then you'll get some iron from that cast-iron leech into your potatoes so that will be good for you.
Or the whole claim of cooking with cast-iron because now you're getting iron and iron deficiency is an issue and that's good for you.
Well, the only truth of that is that, yeah, iron deficiency can be a problem, but we are not supposed to be eating elemental iron.
We're not supposed to be eating iron in the floor of ferrous that is in iron cookware or cast-iron doily thing that you put into your pot of water.
That is not how we get our iron. We don't get our minerals from the soil. We don't eat dirt to get our minerals.
We eat plants to get our minerals. Plants eat dirt, and they convert minerals in the soil to a double bonded, it's key-lated to an amino acid through a double bond.
That's how we should eat our minerals. That's how it's well absorbed and that's how it could get into our cells.
Taking iron or any minerals in a poorly key-lated form can actually cause disease.
It then is acting like a heavy metal in our body and it's damaging to our cells.
It has to be double bonded to an amino acid.
Or do you get that? Well, you get it in your plants.
However, good supplement companies use a nutritional formula later called Trax-T-R-A-A-C-S.
I think it is. And there's another company that does it. They actually have two names.
One bought out the other one. And that's good nutritional companies only use those to formulate their minerals.
So it'll be like iron as iron by glycinate. Or it'll be instead of calcium carbonate, which is limestone from dirt.
There'll be calcium lactate or calcium that's double bonded to an amino acid, calcium glycinate.
Most magnesiums out there on the market are correctly key-lated.
If you go buy something from Walmart or Target, that's where you're going to get these. That's what is a garbage supplement.
They're just made. The minerals are just made from cleaned dirt, cleaned earth.
And you can't assimilate those through the gut. They can actually be damaging to the gut and the things that the minerals that do absorb through the gut in the bloodstream can actually be damaging to the blood vessels and can cause bone spurs and all sorts of stuff.
You have to get your minerals the proper way.
And you see that with copper, too, the whole big fat, double years ago was wearing these copper bracelets.
Well, because it's copper. Yeah, but it's elemental copper. That's it. You know, it's supposed to suck on a copper pipe for crying. Oh, it's poisonous. That's a heavy metal. That's toxic.
It just doesn't make any sense. So is that good to not know.
I mean, just think of it this way. I always tell I always tell people that lecturer nutrition is that eat things the way God intended us to eat things.
We're not supposed to go out there eat dirt plants eat dirt. We eat plants.
So that's if you can think of it that way, it's better. And if you think of your any of your supplements that you're taking, you want them as close to the way God created it.
That's the better way to do it. And most a good supplement company that only sells to professionals is selling good stuff like that. There's just a lot of garbage stuff out there for the public for the unknown public.
And that's why it's cheaper. Hey, well, I was going to buy your minerals, but they're $32 a bottle and I got these a target for 15. Well, yeah, well, you get what you're paying for.
Okay, so that is all our questions for today. Make sure you ask your questions, put them in the in the Q&A form on your course.
And we'll talk to you again in about two weeks. All right, God bless and I'll be praying for all you. Bye bye.